a common complaint that Math teachers
hear is when am I going to need this in
their real world
I get it when I was in high school I
felt like algebra class was pointless a
bunch of imaginary numbers and rules
dreamed up by philosophers trying to
prove to each other how smart they were
but the origins of math are deeply
practical many mathematical Innovations
were invented to solve very real world
problems problems of resource
distribution of Labor compensation Trade
property of determining the very value
of things in other words finance and
even though we modern humans have
calculators and accountants to Crunch
the big numbers for us it still takes an
understanding of math to really know
what your money is doing and what risks
are worth taking
[Music]
to explain how money influenced the
development of mathematics we invited
Naomi Israel a program director with a
non-profit organization bicycle which
teaches high school kids math through
Finance since the beginning of the
species Homo sapiens have had to learn
how to work together and share the
results of that work if two families of
early people managed to bring down a
woolly mammoth how should they split the
meat so that no one gets angry the idea
of fairness was essential to a
Cooperative society which required
methods to measure and count things one
of the earliest numbering systems was
known as a tally stick a piece of wood
or bone with notches carved into it some
day back over ten thousand years the
people who use them probably didn't have
words or even concepts for numbers each
Notch likely corresponded to an item so
they could keep track of their
possessions once humans developed
agriculture this concept was refined
with the invention of the bullet instead
of notches in Wood Sumerian farmers used
small clay tokens to represent their
goods for instance if several farmers
were going to store their Grain Together
they'd use little Sac tokens with
markings to identify whose or whose
these tokens might be said to represent
the first form of math and money to
prevent any funny business the tokens
were sealed in a hollow clay ball called
a bulla and faked so it would have to be
broken open to validate the contents
eventually they started pressing
impressions of the token on the outside
of the ball so it would only have to be
cracked in case of a dispute it wasn't a
big leap from here to realize that they
could press the tokens into a separate
clay tablet and then save room with new
symbols that represented numbers known
as cuneiform script and thus the
accounting Ledger was born over the next
few thousand years Babylonian
mathematics as it's known today made
many important discoveries most of which
were inspired by financial needs if a
tool maker and a Shepherd wanted to
trade they could use conversion ratios
to find out how much each one's goods
were worth in a standardized unit like
sacks of grain for tax purposes the
government had to know how much land
someone owed so they developed
sufficient dedicated ways of measuring
irregular areas the resulting discipline
geometry literally means Earth
measurement and if you needed to split
20 loaves of bread amongst nine workers
you can't do it evenly without inventing
fractions by about 2000 BC the people of
Mesopotamia had started using precious
metals as currency instead of cumbersome
cows and sacks of gray but Metals can't
be counted like cows or measured by area
like land or volume like grain their
value is determined by weight which
means they had to devise methods to
accurately weigh things and create
standardized units as trade exploded
across Europe Asia and Africa many
different civilizations began striking
their own coins of different metals and
levels of Purity this may have
simplified the transportation of
currency but it was a mathematical
headache for instance if you have a 4
gram silver coin it's 70 Purity a 2 gram
coin at 90 Purity and a five grand point
at sixty percent Purity and you melt
them all down and combine them how pure
is the resulting lump of silver problems
like these spurred the development of
Hindu Arabic mathematics around the 9th
or 10th Century The Scholar al-karismi
provided equations or sets of
step-by-step instructions to discover
unknown values from known values algebra
is derived from the Arabic term algebra
and the name al-karismi eventually gave
us the term algorithm to describe a set
of instructions that provide an answer
from an input Hindu Scholars may also
have invented the concept of negative
numbers to represent debt a couple
hundred years later the son of an
Italian Merchant named Leonardo de Pisa
advocated Hindu Arabic mathematics for
many Financial purposes thanks to his
book Liber abachi algebra spread
throughout the Mercantile class in Italy
used for things like establishing
currency exchange rates and calculating
compound interest on loans Fibonacci as
he is more widely known is also credited
with developing present value the notion
that theoretical money in the future is
worth less than the same amount of money
in your hand some fields of Applied
Mathematics also derive from financial
needs mathematicians like General
cardano Blaise Pascal and Pia de Fama
developed gambling strategies that
became the foundation of probability
Theory and the science of Statistics was
greatly Advanced by the needs of the
insurance industry looking to minimize
risk even calculus owes a bit of debt to
finance to save money on wine for his
wedding Johannes Kepler came up with new
equations to find the exact volumes of
barrel shapes which contributed to the
development of integral calculus today
virtually everyone has access to the
Innovations of these mathematical
pioneer years but it wasn't always this
way through much of ancient history the
secrets of math were closely guarded and
the elite who knew them enjoyed special
power and privilege math was the magic
that moved money and money made the
world go round I suppose that's kind of
true today the Wizards of Wall Street
use advanced math to influence the flow
of trillions of dollars that affect
people on every corner of the globe but
you don't have to understand derivative
pricing formulas to benefit financially
from math the math you learn in high
school algebra is all you need to make
many of the financial decisions you will
face in life like investing budgeting
and managing risk sure you can have a
financial advisor do a lot of that work
for you but at the end of the day if you
really want to translate your life goals
into Financial results it helps to speak
the language of math and that's our two
cents
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy click the link
in the description to become a two cents
Patron
for more on the historical Legacy of
money check out our video the history of
the US dollar
foreign